Just hours from
now, Secretary of State
Tony Blinken will be on his way
to a high stakes visit in Beijing.
The U.S.
leaving the door open
for a face
to face meeting
between Blinken and Chinese President
Xi Jinping.
Blinken's trip is happening
in the wake of several
highly charged military
related incidents
between the US and China.
The most recent was earlier
this month in the South China Sea.
You see it
here, a Chinese warship
cutting off a US Navy destroyer.
This is an incident
that was caught on video
as the Chinese ship came dangerously
close here,
just 150 yards
in front of this American ship.
Today,
Blinken said that he is prepared for,
quote, candid conversations.
Oren Liebermann is OUTFRONT
A high stakes visit
with low expectations.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken heads to China
trying to reopen crucial lines
of communication with Beijing.
Intense competition requires
sustained diplomacy
to ensure that competition does not veer
into confrontation with conflict.
And again, that is what the world expects
of both the United States and China.
Blinken's trip was canceled once before
after the U.S.
shot down a Chinese spy balloon
that flew over sensitive U.S.
sites in February.
Since then, relations have declined.
The series of dangerous encounters
between two of the most
powerful militaries on earth
ratcheting up the tensions
in late May.
A Chinese fighter jet
sliced in front of a U.S.
reconnaissance aircraft.
An international airspace
over the South China Sea,
according to the U.S.,
forcing the larger, heavier U.S.
plane
to fly
through the wake turbulence
of the Chinese jet.
Days later in the Taiwan Strait,
a Chinese Navy ship
cut 150 yards in front of a U.S.
destroyer in what the U.S.
called an unsafe
and unprofessional maneuver.
China said the U.S.
was there for provocation.
Earlier, Defense
Secretary Lloyd Austin
shared a handshake
with his Chinese counterpart
in Singapore,
even as Beijing
rejected a formal meeting.
Austin emphasized Friday
that he's ready for dialog.
The door is open
and my phone is that
my phone line is open. And so
they can pick up the
phone and call at any time.
A senior White House
official said dialog is how mature,
strong militaries interact
and the stakes are just too high
to avoid these
critical lines of communication.
But at the highest levels
of the military,
Austin hasn't met
with his Chinese counterpart in a year.
Blinken is now trying to thaw
those frosty relations
as Beijing maintains a deep distrust
about Washington's
intentions for the region and for China.
Mobile Internet and transportation
The U.S.
needs to respect China's core concerns,
stop interfering in China's
internal affairs,
and stop undermining China's sovereignty.
Security and development interests
in the name of competition.
The State Department said
it's not expecting
a breakthrough from this visit,
just a realistic approach
to manage the competition of World powers
in a responsible way.
If we want to make sure as we do that
the competition that we have
with China doesn't veer into conflict,
the place you start
is with communicating.
Defense Secretary Lloyd
Austin told lawmakers one month ago
that the US and the Biden administration
were preparing a weapons drawdown
for Taiwan to ship quickly
and much the same way
the US quickly sends weapons to Ukraine.
But we haven't heard
much about it since then
as we await this further announcement.
Brianna, it certainly seems possible
the US has this on hold right now
so it doesn't disrupt or derail
this delicate diplomatic process
that Blinken will try to advance here
when he departs in just a few hours.
Oren Liebermann, thank you for that.
OUTFRONT now,
Democratic Congressman
Ro Khanna of California,
who is a member of the House
Oversight and Armed Services Committees,
and also the Select Committee on China.
Sir, thank you so much
for taking the time with us this evening.
As you see
Secretary Blinken taking this trip,
what do the deliver rebels need to be?
Does he need to meet
with Xi for this trip to be a success?
Brianna, first of all, it's good
that he's going
I would define success
as just
opening the lines of communication.
If we can get military
to military contact back,
if we can have more regular contact
between our secretary of state
and secretary of defense,
I don't think the benchmarks should be
whether he meets GJ ping if that happens.
That's good.
But the benchmark should be
how do we get communication
going between our two countries?
Bill Gates, the billionaire, met
with Xi today in China.
She called him a, quote, good friend.
And it's notable
because this is a visit that comes
just two weeks after Elon Musk
was in China meeting
with top government officials there.
Does it concern you
that you have
people like Gates
and Musk,
these billionaires
who have a better relationship
with the Chinese government than U.S.
government? Officials do?
Brianna, you're absolutely right.
I mean, you have Bob Iger and Disney, Tim
Cook at Apple, Elon Musk, Bill Gates,
the NBA commissioner,
who frankly, have more in contact
with China than our own military leaders
or our own political leaders.
And I believe that's why we
should applaud
Secretary Blinken going there
so that we have that dialog.
We had dialog
with the Soviet Union
at the height of the Cold War.
And people should reread
President Kennedy's
speech at American University
where he said
we need that dialog even as we seek
to win the Cold War.
So there are places
we have to stand up to China,
but that doesn't preclude dialog.
As I mentioned,
you were on the Armed Services Committee,
so I want to ask you about
Republican Senator Tommy Tuberville,
who is blocking more than 250 nominations
of generals and admirals
because of the Pentagon policy
that provides reimbursement for travel
and also paid time off
for service members
and their family members
who were stationed in states
where abortion is illegal
so that they can receive
reproductive care.
I know you think Tuberville is wrong,
and actually
Mitch McConnell agrees with you,
but does Defense
Secretary Lloyd Austin need to engage
with Tuberville as he is requesting?
Well,
we should not
negotiate with Senator Tupper,
who has was holding up
key promotions for his own
ideological agenda.
I would never do that.
Most Democrats wouldn't do that
just to get our way to hold up
these promotions.
And it matters
because one of the promotions
being held up
is our Joint Chiefs of Staff.
And as you know,
the General Milley
has to retire by October.
And if the president doesn't
get his pick in place,
then we'll have an acting Joint Chiefs
of Staff.
And that hurts our national security.
So I just hope that on this
whatever he other maneuvers
he wants to do, that's his right.
But he shouldn't hold up our military.
Well, it's not held up yet, to be clear.
But it will be held up
if he continues to do this.
And I hear you're saying
not to negotiate with him,
but what other option is there
as you have Republicans
like Cornyn, like Senator
Cornyn, Senator Ernst,
who are offering him
these legislative alternatives and he is
just rebuffing people
even in his own conference?
I mean, what else can be done
at this point?
Well, I think this is
for the leadership
of the Republican caucus to figure out.
I mean, they have responsibly supported
the armed services.
We have disagreements.
But when it comes
to our national security,
that when it comes
to respecting our military,
that's still fortunately a place
where there's bipartisan agreement.
And I
I hope Senator McConnell and Senator
Cornyn will say there are lines
you don't cross.
And one of those lines
is you don't hamper
the president from getting the people
he needs to keep this country safe,
especially when we have threats in China
and the threat of Taiwan.
Congressman, thank you for joining us.
Thank you.